So now you know how to enable
the email and password provider.
Why don't you change the Android code
to allow your users to be created?
I've sent you the login screens
I've been working on, and
they're in a package called login.
We plan to support two types of
login that we're going to use for
the app, email and password,
and Google sign in.
I'll give you a moment to look at them.
We've got two new activities here.
First is the LoginActivity,
which supports both email password and
Google login.
Second, we've got
the CreateAccountActivity.
This creates new users with
the email password login provider.
Now I haven't added any of the Firebase
authentication capabilities yet, so
what I'd like you to do is
start by adding the code for
making a new account in
the CreateAccountActivity.
Afterall, we can't log anybody
in if they're not created.
Here's some code that I copied over
from the Firebase documentation.
It's basically showing you how to use
this createUser method to make a new
user with the email password provider.
To start you get ahold
of a Firebase reference,
then on that reference
to call createUser,
passing in both the email and
password that you want to associate.
Taking a quick look at
the CreateAccountActivity,
I've made two edit texts for you that
have this information that you need.
The name up here is not
something that createUser takes.
We'll discuss how to
incorporate that data in a bit.
This third parameter is something
known as a ResultHandler.
The ResultHandlers have two methods,
onSuccess and onError.
And these get called depending on
whether the new user you're trying to
create, let's say onecooldude@gmail.com,
is successfully added as a new user.
If J.P. successfully adds himself,
the code end onSuccess is called.
If you used ValueResultHandler like I'm
doing here, when onSuccess gets called,
you get an extra little map of
information that contains additional
login information for a new user.
And just a quick note,
when you're creating a user you
actually don't log them in.
You have to call a separate
method to do that.
Now, in Shopping Lists Plus Plus'
login flow,
we don't even want to log them
in when they're on this page.
We have a completely separate activity.
The login activity and
that's where we log our users in.
Now that's pretty much all you
need to know about onSuccess.
The other method in your ResultHandler
is of course the onError method.
And this gets called if
anything happens and
the account is not successfully created.
So why might JP's account
not be successfully added?
Well there's actually a Full Error
Listing on the Firebase documentation,
which provides some insight
in to what could go wrong.
For example, there could already
be an account using that email.
Or the user could have typed something
that isn't perceived as a valid email.
To be able to know which
of these errors occurred,
you'll need to use
the Firebase error parameter,
which will match one of
these errors given here.
That's the argument shown right here.
And once you've figured out what error
occurred, let's say onecooldude was
already taken, you might want to give a
helpful message to the user in some way.
Okay, so can you take this more generic
code here and put it in our app so
that when the user types
in their email and
their password it actually
makes a new user for them?
You'll know you're successful when you
can go to the Firebase dashboard and
see your new account.
So I'm here on the User Login
& Authentication page.
And if I scroll down,
in this area here you'll see
when new accounts get created.
But don't worry about actually
signing in these new users,
that's going to be our next step.